er ist einer der berühmtesten lebenden
sie ressourcen der welt er bekleidet
professuren an den universitäten
princeton und melbourne
der australier peter singer aus
philosoph ist da nicht nur äußerst
erfolgreiche hat auch eine mission er
gegen uns alle dazu bringen unser leben
radikal umzukrempeln um diese ehre für
menschen und tiere zu einem besseren ort
zu machen
seine argumente gehen allerdings einigen
zu weit und immer wieder mussten
veranstaltung mit peter singer wegen
protesten abgesagt werden
1991 wurde er an der universität in
zürich tätlich angegriffen wir sehen
hier die headline der nzz vom 27 mai
1991 peter singer welche erinnerungen
haben sie an diesem abend
das war ein sehr bedauerlicher ereignis
nicht weil ich tätlich angegriffen und
meine brille zertrümmert wurde
obschon das natürlich sehr unangenehm
war frustrierend war vielmehr dass eine
relativ kleine gruppe von leuten nicht
daran hinderte zu einem großen publikum
zu sprechen dessen mehrheit mich hören
wollte
insbesondere sei es in der vordersten
reihe eine gruppe behinderter menschen
in rollstühlen als der zuständige
professor bekannt gab dass wir abbrechen
müssten sagten sie sie wollten eine
diskussion mit mir
sie seien gekommen um sich mit mir
auszutauschen auch sehen waren
frustriert weil das nicht möglich war
nicht mehr möglich weiter zu machen
ihre brille zerbrochen wurde sie sind
stark kurzsichtiger so ohne brille
hätten sie den vortrag nichts weiter
halten können oder der ausschlaggebende
grund abgebrochen haben
ich konnte mir auch kein gehör
verschaffen
denn einige leute nicht die behinderten
sondern die autonomen die hatten
trillerpfeifen und andere geräte
mitgebracht so dass ich mir kein gehör
verschaffen konnte also versuchte ich
etwas auf einen hohlraum projektor zu
schreiben
in diesem moment sprang einer auf die
bühne und zertrümmerte meine brille
sie habe ich selber bin auch behindert
wenn s umsehen geht ohne brille
von da an war nichts mehr zu machen
waren eines der probleme führe eine der
fragen die immer wieder diskutiert
werden im zusammenhang mit ihren
theorien ist eben gerade der status des
behinderten lebens sie vertreten
aussagen wie beispielsweise dass es
legitim sei oder vielleicht sogar
gefordert sei schwerbehinderte säuglinge
umzubringen
das ist relativ schockierend für viele
verstehen sie das gut ich denke es wäre
nicht schockierend wenn menschen einen
moment innehalten und darüber nachdenken
würden was auf intensivstationen und den
spitälern weltweit geschieht
ich bin überzeugt auch hier in zürich
wenn ein kind zur welt kommt zb mit
einer massiven hirnblutungen und das
klar ist dass dieses kind nie ein
unabhängiges leben führen kann dass es
vielleicht nicht einmal in der lage sein
wird je seine mutter an zu lächeln
dann werden die ärzte in die regel den
eltern raten und die behandlung
abzusetzen
die absetzung der behandlung hat bei
einem sehr stark behinderten baby zur
folge dass dieses kind sterben wird
sie wissen dass das baby ohne lebens
unterstützende maßnahmen sterben wird
damit entscheiden sie effektiv das leben
dieses kindes zu beenden
ich sage bloß lasst uns diese art von
verschleierung beenden
diese täuschung bei die wir so tun als
ob wir diese babys nicht töten wenn wir
vorsätzlich entscheiden ihnen
beatmungsgeräte oder andere lebens
unterstützende maßnahmen zu entziehen
wenn wir anerkennen dass wir sie
umbringen macht es dann einen
unterschied ob dir ein atemgerät
abschalten oder ihnen eine tödliche
spritze verabreichen
für viele ist das natürlich ein sehr
großer unterschied für sie aus und
elitär ist nicht vielleicht kann sie
kurz erklären was diese position
bedeutet und warum es für sie keinen
unterschied macht viele touristen geht
es um die konsequenzen einer handlung
ihnen ist weniger wichtig dass man
gewisse regeln befolgt wie du sollst
nicht töten
wichtig sind ihnen die konsequenzen
speziell die konsequenzen in bezug auf
das wohlbefinden aller die von einer
handlung betroffen sind
wenn wir also darüber nachdenken was der
unterschied ist zwischen sagen wir dem
ausschalten des atemgerät und der
verabreichung einer tödlichen spritze
einem sehr schwer behindert neugeborenen
die folgen sind letztlich die gleichen
in der tat ist es besser wenn man die
tödliche spritze verabreicht weil das
baby vielleicht beschwerden hat wenn man
das atemgerät abstellt und es für einige
momente nach luft schnappen muss gut
normalerweise gegen die ärzte
beruhigungsmittel und es würde keinen
unterschied machen der utilitaristische
also sagen wenn die konsequenzen die
gleichen sind für alle betroffenen für
das kind für die eltern beherzte und die
pflegenden dann gibt es wirklich keinen
bedeutenden moralischen unterschied
ich glaube viele leute werden das
akzeptieren wenn sie darüber nachdenken
werden sie realisieren dass es nicht
darauf ankommt auf welche art man ein
leben absichtlich beendet wichtig ist
die entscheidung was für dieses kind und
seine familie besser ist dass das kind
lebt oder das ist stirbt man darf oder
soll schwerbehindert cycling bringt man
hat ihm vorgeworfen dass sie damit in
gefährliche nähe zur nazi ideologie
rücken würde man hat ihnen den
euthanasie vorwurf gemacht das ist für
sie vermutlich auch deswegen leicht
irritierend weil sie selber ja
seiner böhmischen familie stammen aus
einer alten rabbiner familie ihre eltern
sind geflohen vor den nazis drei ihrer
großeltern wurden von den nazis
umgebracht
ein großvater ist im kz theresienstadt
gestorben
müssten nicht gerade sie eine später ein
spezielles verständnis dafür haben dass
ist diese sensibilität gibt gegenüber
der aktiven sterbehilfe geben gegenüber
der frage wo man menschen töten nein das
ist unsinn
für meine unwirklichen großeltern hätte
es keinen unterschied gemacht in die
nazis sie einfach hacken verhungern
lassen statt sie zu vergasen wie ich
bereits gesagt habe wichtig ist die
entscheidung ob jemand leben oder
sterben soll natürlich wenn
menschenleben wollen ist es ein
schreckliches verbrechen ihnen gegen
ihren willen das leben zu nehmen
egal ob durch aktive handlungen oder
indem man sie sterben lässt ob schon an
ihnen hätte helfen können weiterzuleben
[Musik]
natürlich ist es pizza dass das was ich
vorschlage auf irgendeine art und weise
eine analogie zum holocaust sein soll
oder dass es zu so etwas führen könnte
nur in deutschsprachigen ländern wird
das so gesehen
vielleicht ist es ja verständlich
weshalb gerade in deutschsprachigen
ländern
man muss beispielsweise nur von
deutschland über die grenze nach holland
gehen und man trifft auf eine total
andere haltung in holland wird das töten
von schwerbehinderten säuglingen an den
spitälern seit über zehn jahren offen
praktiziert
die anzahl der fälle ist sehr klein nur
eine handvoll aber niemand in holland
käme auf die idee dass man damit das
land in guinea des holocaust rücken
würde
das ist eine bizarre ansicht ein
bizarres missverstehen dessen was ich
sage ging noch einmal zurück zu ihrem
beispiel ein kind kommt zur welt das hat
starke hirnblutungen ist es künstlich
ernährt werden es wird künstlich beatmet
sich auch in einer solchen situation
würden viele eltern gemeinsam mit den
ersten entscheiden möglicherweise die
lebenserhaltenden maßnahmen einzustellen
sei man wahrscheinlich denkt dieses kind
will gar nicht leben oder dieses kind
kann nicht weiterleben ohne alle diese
apparate
das ist doch ein anderer fall wie ein
fall bei dem ein baby zur welt kommt es
ist zwar schwer behindert aber es lebt
ohne irgendwelche weiteren lebte
haltenden maßnahmen die vorstellung dass
ein solches baby nicht leben kann ohne
medizinische unterstützung ist falsch
diese kinder sind lebensfähig wenn man
sie behandelt fährt man mit der
künstlichen beatmung ford können sie
nach einer gewissen zeit nach 12 monaten
selbstständig atmen dann sind sie
lebensfähig und können vielleicht 40
oder 50 jahre leben ohne ihre mutter an
zu lächeln
weil sie dafür nicht genügend
bewusstsein haben aber das wissen sie
nicht sie wissen es nicht
nehmen wir an wir haben ein kind das
viel zu früh zur welt gekommen ist
wenn man es nicht sofort künstlich
beatmet stirbt das baby noch bevor man
einen hirnscan gemacht hat und
festzustellen ob das hirn in ordnung ist
was man also richtigerweise macht man
startet das beatmungsgerät wie atmen ist
künstlich und dann untersuchen wir es
und wenn diese untersuchung zeigt dass
die aussichten auf eine sinnvolle
lebensqualität für dieses kind sehr sehr
gering sind
dann kann man mit den eltern darüber
diskutieren ob das beatmungsgerät
ausgeschaltet werden soll
dies scheint mir unter diesen umständen
das einzig vernünftige vorgehen zu sein
das 1 1 ist aber eines der beispiele
dass sie bringen in ihrem buch
praktische ethik ein buch das heute
ich weiß nicht wie viel auflagen ist
schon hart aber es wird heute von
eigentlich fast alle philosophie
studierenden auch in der schweiz gelesen
das gehört zur pflichtlektüre in diesem
buch gibt es auch ein kapitel über diese
fragen
und dann werden sie das beispiel eines
kleinen kindes das mit der
bluterkrankheit zur welt kommt das sind
ja nun nicht schwerstbehinderte kinder
sondern die haben einen angeborenen
gendefekt haben aber auch jahre vor sich
in denen sie gut leben können
trotzdem sagen sie solche kinder sollten
wir vielleicht einfach ich sage sicher
nicht hier sollten sie töten eltern
könnten sich allenfalls so entscheiden
aber hier geht es mehr um ein
philosophisches fallbeispiel das dazu
dient die menschen zum nachdenken
anzuregen über mögliche entscheidungen
und die gründe dafür
in diesem fall geht es speziell um die
frage ob wir an ein anderes kind denken
dass dieses paar haben könnte um jenes
kind das stirbt zu ersetzen
das interessante am beispiel der
bluterkrankheit ist dass diese heute im
uterus diagnostiziert werden kann wenn
die frau schwanger ist
weil es sich um eine genetische
veranlagung handelt kann man sie
screenen die meisten frauen würden sich
für einen schwangerschaftsabbruch
entscheiden wenn sie erfahren dass ihr
kind ein bluter sein wird weil sie
spüren
ich kann ein anderes kind haben ohne
diese veranlagung und es ist besser
diese veranlagung nicht zu haben
es scheint also dass eine große zahl von
frauen oder paaren den fötus im
mutterleib als ersetzbar betrachten und
dass sie die wahl haben will ich dieses
kind haben dass nun ein fotos in einem
bau fest oder will ich das leben dieses
kindes beenden und ein anderes kind
haben ohne diese veranlagt
ich zitiere dieses beispiel im buch
damit die leute darüber nachdenken ob es
wirklich einen unterschied macht dass
das kind nicht mehr im mutterleib ist
sondern dass die geburt ein paar tage
oder ein zwei wochen zurückliegt
unabhängig davon um über die fälle
sprechen von aktiver sterbehilfe die
viele aus einem problematisch erachten
oder über die fälle der auswahl von
embryonen der selektive abtreibung ist
es so dass menschen personen befürchten
vor allem behinderten organisationen
werfen in die waagschale dass sie sagen
na ja das führt einfach zu einer
abwertung des kranken behinderten lebens
das führt zu einer diskriminierung von
behinderten was haben sie diesen vorwurf
die meisten menschen die über diese
frage nachdenken werden sagen es ist
besser keine behinderung zu haben
die meisten eltern werden so über ihre
eigenen kinder denken viele behinderte
denken so viele dieselbe genetische
behinderungen haben werden tests machen
lassen um nicht ein kind mit einer
erbkrankheit zu bekommen ich bin mir
nicht sicher ob die lieder der aktiven
behinderten bewegungen wirklich
repräsentativ sind dafür wie behinderte
menschen im allgemeinen über diese
problematik denken
schließlich sprechen wir ja von
behinderungen
und wenn man sie heilen könnte würden
die meisten menschen eine heilung
zustimmen es ist so eine art ideologie
geworden dass man nichts sagen darf das
den eindruck erwecken könnte das ein
leben mit behinderung nicht gleich gut
ist wie eines ohne was meines erachtens
nicht der fall ist ein absolutes und in
dieser waagschale sind gar nicht nur die
menschen sondern sind auch die tiere mit
drin die empfindungsfähigkeit tiere auch
die zählen auch die habe moralisch
berücksichtigt zu werden und das wird
dann auch dazu dass sie unter umständen
sagen ist kaum sein dass beispielsweise
menschen auf das überleben dieses
menschenaffen höher gewichtet werden
soll wie möglicherweise das leben eines
schwerstbehinderten das ist auch ein
vergleich den viele aus schockierend
empfinden
ja das tun sie weil wir uns gerne
vorstellen dass es diese riesige kluft
gibt zwischen menschen wie etwas
besonderes sind und tieren die viel
niedriger sind
das geht zurück auf religiöse
traditionen einzig wir wurden nach
gottes ebenbild geschaffen wir haben
unsterbliche seele gott erschuf uns nach
der übrigen welt und von ihr getrennt
für mich ist das unsinn
ich glaube viele denken dass das unsinn
ist wir alle stammen von tieren ab das
wissen wir seit darwin
es gibt keinen kontinuum zwischen
menschen und tieren wir wurden nicht
nach gottes bild erschaffen
es geht nicht um einen vergleich
zwischen mensch und tier sondern darum
individuen miteinander zu vergleichen
man könnte argumentieren dass normale
menschen mit ihren überlegenen
kognitiven fähigkeiten wertvoller sind
so würde ich das zwar nicht sagen aber
man könnte argumentieren dass es
schlimmer sei deren leben zu beenden als
das leben einer kreatur die nicht über
diese kognitiven fähigkeiten verfügt der
punkt ist der dass man damit keine linie
zwischen der spezies homo sapiens mit
all ihren mitgliedern und allen
mitgliedern der anderen arten zieht
vielmehr kommt es zu überschneidungen
mitglieder von anderen arten dazu
gehören wie sie gesagt haben schimpansen
oder gorillas mindestens vielleicht auch
elefanten und viele andere deren
kognitive fähigkeiten sind jenen von
einigen mitgliedern unserer art
überlegen sie sagen ich würde ein
absolutes recht auf leben verneinen die
einzigen menschen die das nicht tun sind
menschen die kein einziges lebewesen
töten
jeder andere lehnt ein absolutes recht
auf leben ab für gewisse kreaturen genau
aber warum
das ist die frage warum sollten wir
denken dass uns nur weil wir zur art
homo sapiens gehören ein absolutes recht
auf leben zu stehen
und wenn sie nicht dazu gehören sondern
zb ein mitglied der art pantanis kuss
ein schimpanse sind dann haben sie kein
absolutes recht auf leben das ist für
mich ein relikt von religiösem lenkt
ich sehe keinen anderen grund ein
versuch versucht mit menschen offen oder
mit sonstigen offen an der oxford
university gutgeheissen grundsätzlich
sind ja gegen tierversuche aber sie
haben gesagt da ging es um eine studie
um ein medikament gegen parkinson zu
finden und sie haben gesagt das lässt
sich rechtfertigen diese versuche mit
offen weil wenn wir ein medikament
finden könnten das allen parkinson
kranken hilft dann wäre es auch
gerechtfertigt gewissen offen dieses
leiden zuzufügen
könnte man nicht wenn man ihre theorie
ernst nimmt sagen naja dann lass uns
doch diese versuche in zukunft mit
demenzkranken machen wenn sie damit
menschen meinen die einmal über
bewusstsein verfügten und in der lage
waren zu sagen ob sie damit
einverstanden wären oder nicht dass man
sie für solche versuche als probanden
einsetzt dann müsste man sie fragen und
wenn sie bereit sind und ihr
einverständnis geben ist dies
möglicherweise eine vertretbare praxis
die affen nicht fragen
[Musik]
das kommt auf die art des versuchs an
für gewisse versuche gibt es
offensichtlich freiwillige aber sie
haben recht die hafen kann man nicht
fragen
vielleicht muss ich noch beifügen beim
forschungs experiment von dem ich sagte
sei möglicherweise gerechtfertigt
stützte ich mich auf die faktenlage
ich akzeptierte die darstellung dass es
keinen anderen weg gebe eine behandlung
für parkinsonkranke zu finden dass die
wahrscheinlichkeit eines erfolgs sehr
groß sei und dass dieser versuch vielen
helfen würde
ich konnte selber nicht verifizieren ob
diese fakten korrekt waren deshalb
behandelte ich den fall als hypothese
unter der voraussetzung dass diese
fakten korrekt sind könnte der versuch
gerechtfertigt werden
geht sie wurden angegriffen dafür dass
sie ihre eigene alzheimer kranke mutter
liebevoll pflegen ließen während sie
eigentlich auch in verschiedenen
schriften sagen es gibt zustände mentale
zustände krankheiten die uns dazu führen
dass wir eigentlich eben diese menschen
anfangs töten dürfen aktive sterbehilfe
sollte erlaubt sein auch bei schwer
fortgeschrittenen demenz kranken wie
sind sie mit diesem widerspruch
umgegangen
für mich gibt es da überhaupt keinen
widerspruch
meine mutter lebte in australien
australien erlaubt keine euthanasie und
auch keine sterbehilfe für menschen mit
demenz wenn ich ihr leben aktiv beendet
hätte hätte ich ein paar jahre im
gefängnis verbracht
das hätte sie nicht gewollt deshalb war
das gar nie eine option
ich muss auch noch beifügen dass ich
nicht das einzige kind meiner mutter bin
da war auch noch meine schwester und
natürlich ist mir der erhalt der
familien harmonie sehr wichtig aber ich
bin überzeugt wäre sterbehilfe in
solchen fällen legal gewesen hätte meine
mutter bevor sie dement wurde ein
entsprechendes dokument unterzeichnet
und zu sagen dass sie dies wollen und
dann wäre klar gewesen dass es richtig
ist es zu tun
ja wenn das ihr wille gewesen wäre und
ich denke viele würden das tun
in der tat hatte die new york times
gerade letzten sonntag eine geschichte
über eine frau mit demenz die ihr leben
beenden wollte
bevor ihr zustand zu schlecht sein würde
um zu handeln
das war für alle nachvollziehbar und ihr
mann und ihre familie willigten ein
so kamen sie noch einmal bei ihr
zusammen um sich zu verabschieden
wissend dass sie es tun wird vielleicht
auch schockiert und denken sie darin
eine person die menschenverachtende züge
hätte
gleichzeitig haben sie theorien
vorgelegt bezüglich der weltweiten
eigentum und den eindruck kriegt es gibt
eigentlich keine menschen lieben der re
person wie sie sie engagieren sich für
die steigerung der entwicklungshilfe wie
kaum ein anderer philosoph den ich kenne
sie fordern beispielsweise dass sie
mindestens zehn prozent unseres
einkommens abgeben sollten für die
entwicklungshilfe
es gibt sicher viele die uns jetzt
zuschauen die tun was nicht
wahrscheinlich die allermeisten spenden
nicht so viel sie haben jetzt die chance
für sie zu überzeugen was ist ihr
argument das argument lautet die ihr
leben sehr bequeme sogar luxuriöse leben
wenn ich hier sage meine jeden der sich
zumindest zur mittelklasse zählt in den
zentral und westeuropäischen ländern in
australien den usa
wir geben geld aus wir alle möglichen
dinge die wir nicht brauchen
gleichzeitig gibt es auf dieser welt
eine milliarde menschen die mit weniger
als einem dollar 50 pro tag leben müssen
das sind eineinviertel euro pro tag sie
können ihre kinder oft nicht vor
tödlichen krankheiten schützen
krankheiten von denen wir wissen wie man
sie verhindern oder heilen kann wie
malaria masern oder durchfall
sie müssen zuschauen wie ihre kinder
sterben und wir sind in der lage ihnen
zu helfen
genauso wie es in diesen ländern
menschen gibt die blind sind nur weil
sie sich eine einfache operation nicht
leisten können der sich in einem
wohlhabenden land jeder unterzieht die
einen grauen star entwickelt menschen in
wohlhabenden ländern erblinden nicht am
grauen star aber weltweit gibt es
millionen von menschen die blind sind
bei
sie sich die entfernung des grauen stars
nicht leisten können deshalb gibt es
organisationen die unsere spenden
entgegennehmen
damit menschen wieder sehen können im
leben von kindern in entwicklungsländern
zu retten
um familien eine bessere lebensqualität
zu ermöglichen damit mädchen zur schule
gehen und eine ausbildung machen können
eine ganze reihe von maßnahmen die
gemessen an unserem standard mit sehr
wenig geld umgesetzt werden können
das ist sehr günstig ist für uns gibt es
sonst noch einen unterschiedenen hier
noch einmal jetzt auf das vorherige
thema blicken da ging es darum dass sie
gesagt haben es gibt krankheiten
behinderungen die sind so schwer dass
sich das leben eigentlich nicht nur und
weiter zulegen dürften diese menschen
töten gleichzeitig jetzt die blinden in
entwicklungsländern die können wir
relativ einfach heilen also was ist
genau der unterschied waren sollen die
heißen und wann ist es legitim nicht zu
helfen wo ich schon es geht nicht um den
entscheid zu helfen oder hilfe zu
unterlassen
wenn wir das leben eines kindes beenden
dass ein elendes leben oder überhaupt
kein bewusstsein haben wird dann helfen
wir dem kind bei seiner familie
meiner meinung nach geht es in all
diesen fällen um hilfe es ist bloß eine
frage die umstände in manchen fällen ist
die beste form der hilfeleistung leiden
zu beenden
und manchmal können wir dies nur indem
wir das leben beenden
in anderen fällen haben wir kein problem
leiden zu beenden weil wir wissen was
und wie wir es tun müssen
diese menschen können ein gutes
lebenswertes leben haben
für mich ist das absolut das gleiche es
geht um den versuch unnötiges leiden in
den verschiedenen formen in denen es
vorkommt zu reduzieren
maximieren können sondern es geht noch
um ganz andere werte ich würde gerne
genaueres über diese ganz anderen werte
erfahren
ich denke wir alle verstehen dass die
reduktion von leiden ein wert ist dass
die verlängerung von leben solange es
lebenswert ist einen wert darstellt und
dass wir dies mit größtmöglichen einsatz
versuchen sollten
ich denke es bräuchte ein sehr starkes
argument wenn man zeigen wollte dass es
andere werte gibt die verletzt werden
wenn man versucht so viel gutes zu tun
wie man kann ich bin nicht überzeugt
dass es diese anderen werte gibt die
gesellschaft die die tschuldigung das
new yorker lincoln center betreut hat
bekannt gegeben dass der musik und
filmproduzent david geffen 100 millionen
us dollar gespendet hat um die avery
fisher hall zu renovieren eine sehr
berühmte konzerthalle über alle größen
der musikindustrie auftreten und diese
avery fisher hall gibt dann auch
natürlich david gästen heißen und sie
haben das kritisiert die haben gesagt
dieser david geffen hätte mit diesem
geld viel viel bessere dinge machen
können
das ist doch ein gutes beispiel wie
wahrscheinlich port williams der
gestorben ist sagen würde
es gibt noch andere werte beispielsweise
klassische musik großartigen konzert
hören zu können sich ergreifen zu lassen
von der musik kunst überhaupt
ich würde niemals bestreiten dass das
hören von klassischer musik etwas
wertvolles ist und sie in einem
konzertsaal zu hören ist herrlich aber
die tatsache dass dieser konzertsaal
sehr teuer renoviert worden ist hat
meiner ansicht nach keinen
entscheidenden einfluss auf dieses
erlebnis
die reichen new yorker oder die
internationalen touristen die diesen
saal besuchen und sowieso ein sehr gutes
leben führen haben jetzt einfach einen
etwas schöneren konzertsaal
während für 100 millionen dollar lassen
sie mich auf mein vorheriges beispiel
zurückkommen jemandem das augenlicht
wieder zurückgeben der am rauen star
erblindet ist kostet möglicherweise
weniger als 100 dollar nehmen wir mal an
es kostet 100 dollar das heißt eine
million menschen hätten dafür ihr
augenlicht zurück gehalten können und
werden vielleicht für zehn oder fünfzehn
weitere jahre in der lage wieder zu
sehen
ich kann mir einfach nicht vorstellen
dass eine vernünftige person sagen würde
dass es wichtiger ist diesen konzertsaal
zu renovieren als eine million menschen
das augenlicht zurück zu geben
danach ausrichten wo ich mehr positiv
nutzen
darüber müssten vermutlich alle vermehrt
nachdenken vor allem junge menschen die
vor der berufswahl stehen
es ist nicht immer einfach umzusteigen
für mich ist es definitiv zu spät sie
sind jünger als ich sie haben bessere
karten
ich bin auf alle fälle jungen menschen
sagen und das ist etwas das die aktion
effektiver altruismus an der ich
beteiligt bin tot
die bewegung ermutigt menschen ihre
laufbahn unter dem gesichtspunkt zu
betrachten wie sie in der welt am
meisten gutes tun können
ich finde ein fernsehprogramm zu
betreiben dass viele menschen dazu
bringt über ethische fragen nachzudenken
leistet viel gutes weil es menschen dazu
bringt ethisch bessere entscheidungen zu
treffen
nein das glaube ich nicht
in allen kulturen gibt es musik und
kunst egal ob menschen dafür bezahlt
werden oder nicht
vielleicht gibt es keine sehr gut
ausgebildeten wunderbaren
sinfonieorchester mehr wenn wohltätige
menschen stattdessen ihr geld an
hilfsorganisationen spenden menschen in
extremer armut unterstützen
[Musik]
aber ich bin überzeugt dass es weiterhin
orchester geben
und menschen die musizieren und ich
denke es wird immer noch ein genuss sein
ein etwas anderer aber ich bin nicht so
sicher dass er auch geringer sein wird
die meisten ihrer bücher sind ja auch
dazu da und das ist nur einen sparsamen
1 ein mini auszug ihres großen großen
werks die sind dazu da die welt zu
verbessern titel wie leben retten kann
sie sollen ihr leben aber sie haben auch
ein buch geschrieben eben über ihren
großvater der im kz theresienstadt
umgebracht wurde dieser ernst oppenheim
ein berühmter mann david ernst oppenheim
er hat zusammen mit sigmund freud
kompliziert sind und freud hat ihm sogar
eine fußnote gewichts mit in seiner
traumdeutung schreiben sie dann später
wieder raus gefahren ist war der
offenbar eher bei urlaubern angesiedelt
war
aber dieses buch ist ja ein buch bei dem
in dem sie sich sozusagen mit ihrer
geschichte auch auseinandersetzen ihren
vorfahren auseinandersetzen das ist ja
ein buch das haben sie sich ein stück
weit auch geleistet eben im sinne eines
künstlerischen werks wenn man so will
damit haben sie nicht leben retten
wollen das stimmt ich schrieb dieses
buch in den 1990 er jahren damals war
ich noch nicht so engagiert für diese
idee des effektiven altruismus wie ich
es heute wahrscheinlich würde ich heute
anders darüber denken wenn es darum
ginge ein oder zwei jahre für das
schreiben dieses buches einzusetzen
obwohl ich es gerne gemacht habe und es
für meine familie von bedeutung war
und ich weiß dass es auch für viele
andere menschen richtig war
die mir sagten sie kämen aus ähnlichen
familien mit ähnlichen erfahrungen
aber es stimmt gemessen am anspruch des
effektiven atheismus die größtmöglichen
verbesserungen in der welt zu versuchen
hätte ich meine zeit vielleicht besser
nutzen können
sprechen wir mal darüber was ich jetzt
zum beispiel tun sie also sie sagen in
ihren büchern eben leben retten
gehen sie auf die website der live hier
kein safe das ist eine organisation die
gegründet haben
da kann man berechnen lassen wie viel
man spenden sollte man sieht auch
welchen organisationen man eben spenden
könnte die besonders effektiv arbeiten
wo das geld dann eben nicht irgendwo
versickert aber der grundtenor ist schon
spende und geräte leben spende und
verändere die welt das ist ein relativ
individualistische bild von hilfe von
entwicklungshilfe und die wurde ja auch
kritisiert ich möchte gerne mit ihnen
zusammen einen ausschnitt ansehen auf
dem tech talk von dem uganda an ruanda
der diese sichtweise diskreditiert für
alle die sich wirklich für afrika
interessieren geht es nicht darum die
armut zu bekämpfen sondern darum wie
können wir wohlstand erzeugen
da müssen wir ansetzen wenn sie sagen
afrikaner sind arm wir müssen ihre armut
bekämpfen
dann steht ihnen der ganze
internationale katalog von guten
absichten zur verfügung
sie können den armen medikamente bringen
den hungrigen nahrung und den von
bürgerkriegen heimgesuchten
friedensmissionen dies gibt es vorläufig
aber nichts von alledem ist produktiv
denn sie bekämpfen damit lediglich die
symptome aber nicht die ursachen von
afrikas und mentalen problemen
zuerst will ich die ursachen für afrikas
armut kennen
da gibt es nicht nur einen grund es gibt
viele verschiedene gründe
sicherlich würde ich gerne diese
ursachen beheben
aber möglicherweise ist das sehr
schwierig wenn sie sich studien
anschauen was zu armut flat da gibt es
eine reihe von faktoren
wir könnten das globale handelssystem
verbessern dass viele schlechte seiten
hat die tatsache dass die eu und die
vereinigten staaten ihre
landwirtschaftlichen produkte
subventionieren
ist schlecht wie afrika weil es zur
folge hat dass die afrikanischen bauern
auf dem weltmarkt nicht konkurrenzfähig
sind angesichts der subventionierten
produkte aus den reichen ländern gut
wäre wenn wir das ändern könnte
es gibt viele weitere gründe laut
experten die dies untersuchen sind
manche ursachen geografischer art länder
sind arm in bezug auf ihre produktivität
ihre landwirtschaftliche produktivität
ihr klima manche sind binnenländer sie
haben keinen hafen und möglicherweise
auch keine guten straßen um produkte
durch ein nachbarland an einen hafen zu
transportieren
es gibt viele unterschiedliche gründe
unbedingt würde ich sagen lasst uns
diese ursachen bekämpfen überall dort wo
es möglich ist
gleichzeitig sollten wir es aber nicht
unterlassen jenen menschen zu helfen die
es nötig haben wenn wir menschen helfen
können lasst es uns tun die leute sagen
immer das sei bloß ein heftpflaster aber
brauchen sie nie ein heftpflaster
heftpflaster sind sie nützliche dinge
und in diesem fall stoppt es nicht nur
die blutung an meiner hand es rettet
leben gibt blinden das augenlicht zurück
oder schickt mädchen zur schule
gerade wenn man auf die folgen schaut ja
das führt zu einer gewissen abhängigkeit
dieser länder die richten sich dann ein
in der entwicklungshilfe und die
politischen eliten die korrupten
erlebten die bürger kriegsführenden
führen sich nicht fühlen sich nicht in
der pflicht wirklich etwas zu ändern
lassen sie uns nicht unterstellen dass
alle afrikanischen regierungen korrupt
sind
lassen sie uns nicht annehmen dass es in
allen afrikanischen ländern bürgerkrieg
ich finde dies ist ein sehr negatives
image das zu einem gewissen grad von den
medien kreiert wird die nicht auf länder
wie zum beispiel ghana fokussieren
von dort wird man viel weniger als von
ländern wie etwa dem kongo wo ein
bürgerkrieg im gang ist
die meisten guten hilfsorganisationen
wissen um die problematik der
abhängigkeit sie strukturieren ihre
hilfe so dass sie versuchen
diese abhängigkeit zu verhindern ich
behaupte nicht dass es da kein
potenzielles problem gibt
wir dürfen deshalb aber nicht sagen wir
helfen euch nicht wir lassen euch wo ihr
seid weil sonst die gefahr besteht dass
ihr oder euer land in abhängigkeit
geraten waren regelrechte sozialreformer
ihnen war ein politisches programm ganz
ganz wichtig sonst überhaupt
beispielsweise für die rechte der frauen
gekämpft bei ihnen hat man doch immer
ein bisschen das gefühl dass dieser
individualistische blick wichtiger ist
obwohl sie auch ein buch geschrieben
haben oneworld das sehr politisch ist
aber es wurde weniger wahrgenommen wie
viele andere bücher und in diesem
zusammenhang habe ich mich mal gefragt
warum äussern sich eigentlich in meinem
eindruck relativ selten wirklich
politisch aber sie äußern sich dann
politisch wenn es um die tierrechte geht
sie würden ja nie sagen wir sollen den
tieren einfach nicht das futter geben
aber sie einsperren sondern sie möchten
gerne dass die tiere frei sein können
animation ist eines ihrer wichtigen
bücher also rechte für tiere sind ganz
ganz wichtig aber wenn es um
entwicklungshilfe geht dann scheint
ihnen der hilfs gedanke in erster linie
am herzen zu liegen und nicht so sehr
die politische veränderung der
strukturen
ich glaube nicht dass das stimmt ich
spreche auch über individuen wenn es um
die tierrechtsbewegung geht
ich sage dass menschen aufhören sollten
fleisch zu essen das ist ein
individueller beitrag gegen das leiden
der tiere nicht dass die rechte
zugesprochen kriegen nein das ist es
nicht
ich bin kein tier rechtsanwalt ja in
diesem speziellen fall um einen
zusammenhang herzustellen zur situation
von menschen aber grundsätzlich stelle
ich meine auffassungen über die
veränderungen die es bezüglich unseres
umgangs mit tieren braucht nicht auf
eine rechtliche basis
andere leute in der tierrechtsbewegung
tun das aber meine position ist es nicht
was ich aber noch sagen wollte
in gewissen phasen meiner laufbahn war
ich politisch engagiert ich war zweimal
kandidat der australischen grünen für
das bundesparlament ich war ein
gründungsmitglied der australischen
grünen und ich schrieb ein buch das sie
nicht kennen weil es in erster linie für
ein australisches publikum war es trägt
den titel the greens und ich schrieb es
zusammen mit bob brown co gründer und
erster leader der grünen in australien
ich war also politisch engagiert zu
verschiedenen zeitpunkten meiner
laufbahn
und ich finde dass ich es bis zu einem
gewissen grad immer noch bin aber ich
bin auch zur einsicht gelangt dass
politische prozesse oft sehr langsam
sind wenn man etwas verändern vielleicht
gewann ich diesen eindruck auch deshalb
weil ich die letzten 15 jahre in den usa
gelebt habe und ich finde dass das us
amerikanische politische system wirklich
ein schlamassel ist es ist wahnsinnig
schwierig die nötigen veränderungen zu
erzielen was ich den leuten sage ist ihr
dürft euch nicht machtlos fühlen nur
weil das politische system derart
deformiert ist dass man nichts erreicht
es gibt dinge die einzelne bürger tun
können
das ist oft auch das thema beim
effektiven altruismus
wir versuchen nicht die leute davon
abzuhalten sich politisch zu engagieren
aber wir sagen dass man wirkungsvolle
dinge tun kann
[Musik]
übrigens sollte ich erwähnen dass die
schweiz eines der zentren des effektiven
altruismus ist nach oxford und den usa
befindet sich das glaube ich drittgrößte
zentrum hier in der schweiz
wenn sich ihre zuschauer dafür
interessieren können sie effektiv atrium
switzerland googeln um es zu finden
die da mitmachen wenn ich jetzt darauf
die website gehe und mir die sachen
anschaue dann finde ich organisiere für
die spenden könnte ich sollte ihnen
gemäß mindestens zehn prozent meines
einkommens abgeben wenn ich jetzt eher
politisch interessiert bin und mir sage
ich möchte gerne die welt verändern ich
glaube aber an die politik trotzdem ich
glaube an politik politische lösungen
wenn ich jetzt dieses geld nehmen und
meiner lieblings parteispenden wir denn
hin immer noch an es ist eine partei
die viel für die
entwicklungszusammenarbeit tut das wäre
ja trotzdem nicht in ihrem sinn wir
sollen diese engine aus berücksichtigen
nein das ist okay wenn sie über eine
strategie nachgedacht haben die so
aufgehen könnte wenn sie zum beispiel
eine partei haben in der lage ist die
handelspolitik des landes zu ende und
dessen bürgerin sie sind oder die
hilfsgelder zu erhöhen
oder dass es mit anderen ländern
zusammen arbeitet wir haben zb noch
nicht einmal über den klimawandel
gesprochen
der für die armen der welt zu einer
katastrophe wird dafür braucht es eine
politische lösung
ich glaube nicht dass hier individuelle
antworten ausreichen wenn jemand sagt
ich will meine mittel für politische
arbeit einsetzen da es mein einkommen
meine energie oder zeit so könnte sich
der einsatz lohnen auf bei relativ
geringer erfolgschancen
weil die wirkung groß ist dies ist kein
gegensatz zu meinen auffassungen und
auch nicht zu jenen der bewegung des
effektiven altruismus
ich möchte gerne zeit und energie
investieren die lokalen organisationen
beispielsweise nachbarschaftshilfe darin
dass menschen die in altenheimen in der
schweiz leben mehr besucher kriegen ich
starte ein projekt nachbarschaftshilfe
für alte vereinsamte menschen und stecke
alle zeit und energie da rein
ich denke die meisten effektiven
altruisten finden dass sie ihre zeit und
energie besser nutzen könnten um etwas
wirksameres für die menschheit zu tun
angesichts der tatsache dass es den
menschen in ihrer näheren umgebung die
in einer wohlstandsgesellschaft leben
vermutlich sowieso recht gut geht
aber vielleicht haben sie kein geld das
sie entbehren können aber sie haben zeit
oder sie können sich zusammen mit ihren
nachbarn organisieren um alte menschen
in den heimen zu besuchen was dieser auf
und hat dort das ist eine möglichkeit
ich bin überhaupt nicht dagegen dass man
das tut ich würde einzig sagen bevor sie
annehmen dass die beste möglichkeit zu
lokal ist sollten sie sich überlegen ob
sie nicht anderswo mehr bewirken könnten
sie selber leben bescheiden sie haben
immer mindestens zehn ihres einkommens
gespendet im laufe der letzten jahre
wurde das fast 40 prozent kann man lesen
verschiedenen interviews mit ihnen war
ihre frau renata nicht immer auf ihr ja
zum glück war sie das es ist sehr gut
dass wir beide gleicher meinung waren
ich war derjenige der zuerst fand dass
wir so etwas tun sollten
aber auch sie war demgegenüber von
beginn weg sehr positiv eingestellt
das war wirklich wichtig für mich
wenn sie dagegen gewesen wäre wäre es
für mich sehr schwierig geworden dass
alleine durchzuziehen aber zum glück
teilen wir viele unserer grundlegenden
werte ich finde das ist wirklich wichtig
in einer beziehung so haben wir das
zusammen getan
ein buch ganz verschiedene literarische
beispiele nehmen um eben fragen der
ethik eid zu diskutieren
das haben sie zusammen herausgegeben sie
und ihre frau arbeiten sie öfters
zusammen lesen sie voneinander was sie
schreiben ja klar habe ich die romane
gelesen die sie geschrieben hat und sie
liest meine arbeiten und gibt ihre
kommentare dazu nicht alle die eher
akademischen nicht vielleicht schreibe
ich zu viel aber auf alle fälle liest
sie jene die sich an ein breiteres
publikum richten
und ja wir haben über die jahre belegen
dass zusammengearbeitet was dieses buch
anbelangt sie ist breiter als ich mehr
romane
das war eine echte zusammenarbeit sie
hat eine reihe von passagen und beispiel
vorgeschlagen die wir dann zusammen
diskutiert habe
aber sie hatte immer auch ihre eigene
arbeit
sie schreibt an einem buch über gutes
leben jenseits von 60 was wir jetzt sind
die frage des längeren lebens wie man
diese lebensphase genießen kann ist ein
wichtiges thema heute wo die menschen
länger leben auch darüber reden wir aber
das ist ihre arbeit nicht mein aber
nicht selber und diese situation denke
wie die nicht interessieren haben sie
das als vater gemacht wenn ihr was
weihnachten ins haus schneit dann geht s
nimmer so mit meinen kindern man könnte
ihnen ja tausende von geschenken machen
aber wenn man das vergleicht mit dem was
andere kinder haben dann kommt man ins
grübeln gerade in der weihnachtszeit
das ist schwierig man muss ständig gegen
die vorstellung ankämpfen dass der
haufen von geschenken wächst wie die
kinder oder jetzt bei uns natürlich die
grosskinder wir haben versucht die zahl
die geschenke zu reduzieren
aber ich will nicht behaupten dass uns
das ganz gelungen ist
ich sage nicht dass jedermann auf dem
gleichen niveau leben soll wie die
menschen in armut das ist unrealistisch
ich glaube man muss akzeptieren dass
menschen für ihre kinder und ihre
nächsten angehörigen mehr tun als für
fremde aber diese vorgeschlagenen summen
ob es nun zehn prozent sind gerade zu
beginn auf weniger auf der website
schlage ich einen betrag vor der bezug
nimmt auf das einkommen
er kann also anfänglich unter zehn
prozent betragen und darüber hinaus
gehen wenn ihr einkommen wächst
ich denke man kann das tun und
gleichzeitig seinen kindern an
weihnachten seine liebe beweisen
ohne zu übertreiben und ohne sie in
diesen materialismus der
konsumgesellschaft hinein zu drängen
bei ihm alles davon abhängt das neueste
computerspiel oder videogeräte zu haben
oder das neueste smartphone oder was
auch immer
[Musik]
an ihre kinder nie wütend auf sie solle
ihre frau dass sie gesagt haben es
reicht jetzt hier mal mit moralischen
wir wollen auch einfach was die anderen
haben
nein ich glaube nicht dass sie sich so
benachteiligt fühlten
ich weiß nicht nein sie unterstützen uns
manchmal wollten sie einen teil ihres
taschengeldes hergeben um selber
menschen in armut zu helfen
es gibt ethiker die gehen noch einen
schritt weiter die sagen eigentlich ist
es gar nicht legitim eigene kinder zu
haben wir sollten besser darauf
verzichten und kinder adoptieren aus
sehr armen ländern sie haben drei eigene
kinder warum haben sie nicht die option
gewählt
für mich wäre das einen schritt zu weit
gegangen denke ich meine frau und ich
wollten beide eigene kinder
ich bewundere menschen die kinder
adoptieren und finde es gut das zu tun
ob schon heute gibt es auch gewisse
probleme bei adoptionen von kindern aus
entwicklungsländern
es ist schwierig festzustellen ob es
wirklich um fälle von menschen in not
geht weil ihnen die regel auf irgendeine
art und weise immer geld im spiel ist
da gibt es also einige fragezeichen
aber sehen sie ich finde kinder zu
adoptieren ob aus dem eigenen land oder
aus dem ausland kann gut sein für jene
die dazu bereit sind
ich finde aber eigene kinder zu haben
ist eine sehr zentrale lebenserfahrung
und ich würde nicht von anderen etwas
fordern was ich mir und meiner frau
nicht zugemutet habe nämlich auf diese
erfahrung zu verzichten
es glaubt wahrscheinlich nicht immer
beispielsweise haben die lehrstühle in
princeton und in melbourne sie werden
fliegen müssen lässt sich vielleicht
nicht vermeiden
aber wenn ich so den großteil der
menschen angucke dann leben ja die
wenigsten so wie sie denken sie sich das
könnte ein hinweis darauf sein dass sie
ihre theorie einfach zu anspruchsvoll
ist
vermutlich gehen meine vorstellungen die
meisten leuten zu weit
ich denke aber sie können trotzdem ein
ansporn sein ob sie nun erreichen oder
nicht
deshalb sage ich man kann auf einer sehr
tiefen stufe mit dem geben anfangen
ich hoffe dass menschen das ausprobieren
und sich damit anfreunden und es dann
vielleicht noch besser machen wollen
ich glaube dass wir langsam schritt für
schritt die kultur verändern können so
dass es normale wird etwas zu geben und
es den leuten leichter fällt weil sie
sich daran gewöhnt haben weil es ein
teil ihrer kultur geworden ist auch
schon ich selber versuche mehr zu tun
mache ich leuten die nicht so leben wie
ich keinen vorwurf
wenn sie einige schritte in diese
richtung machen ist das schon ein guter
anfang
[Musik]
wir glauben ihnen einfach gar nicht die
sagen der irrt sich doch einfach
vollkommen nicht auf doch noch mein
eigenes leben leben es geht doch nicht
darum alles im leben nur daraufhin
auszutarieren ob ich die welt zu einem
besseren leben mache ist und es geht
auch darum was möchte ich für eine
person sein was möchte ich aus meinem
leben machen aus diesem geschenk das ich
erhalten habe diese zeit die vielleicht
die einzige ist wenn ich nicht auf die
wiedergeburt glaube dann möchte ich was
draus machen was ganz spezielles ich
möchte zb viel bergsteigen gehen oder
ich möchte mein geld darauf verwenden
kunst zu kaufen welches wie soll ich
sagen
was ist eigentlich ihr ihre idee
dahinter dass sie denken alle leute
sollten diese schritte in diese richtung
tun
jeder sollte begreifen dass wir in einer
welt leben in der es einige sehr ernste
probleme gibt die weltweite armut gehört
zu diesen problemen das leiden das wir
tieren antun ist ein weiteres großes
problem dass dutzende von milliarden
fühlende wesen betrifft ein anderes
riesiges problem ist wie ich bereits
erwähnt habe die klimawandel einfach zu
sagen ich nehme von all dem keine notiz
ich kaufe kunst und umgebe mich mit
kunst
oder ich erkläre so viele bergspitzen
wie ich kann das scheint mir zu genuss
orientiert sich von den realitäten der
welt in der wir leben einfach abzuwenden
damit will ich nicht sagen dass sich
diese beiden dinge nicht genieße kunst
oder einen berg zu besteigen
wenn man das aber zu seinem wichtigsten
lebensziel erhebt scheint mir erkennt
man den beitrag der an diese welt
geleistet werden könnte
die aufrichtig das leben geht sie
besteht niemanden sie lügt nicht sie ist
freundlich zu anderen menschen sie hilft
vielleicht da und dort mal wo sie kann
aber die interessiert dich nicht groß
dafür was in anderen ländern passiert
ist es eine person die in ihren augen
bereichen
leider ist die antwort darauf ja das ist
ein sehr traditionelles konzept dessen
was man unter einem moralischen oder
ethischen leben versteht dieses konzept
wurde zu einer zeit entwickelt als
menschen im kleinen gesellschaften
bieten und das genügte dass sie die von
ihnen erwähnten regeln befolgten
vermutlich gab es auch nicht viel dass
sie tun konnten um menschen in der ferne
zu helfen
wie auch immer sie wussten nicht
genügend darüber oder hatten nicht die
mittel um zu helfen
heute aber leben wir in einer sehr
anderen welt in einer welt der echtzeit
kommunikation und des schnellen
transport in einer welt wo alles
miteinander verbunden ist
das ist der leitgedanke des buches
oneworld dass sie erwähnt habe dies
alles einfach zu ignorieren und zu sagen
ich begnüge mich damit die regeln zu
befolgen indem ich niemandem schade
nicht betrüge das scheint mir nicht
genug die globalisierung gibt uns
eigentlich noch mehr moralische
hausaufgaben
ja absolut einerseits ja aber natürlich
ist unser leben heute viel angenehmer
als früher krankheiten sind keine so
große bedrohungen mehr zumindest für uns
bewohner der wohlhabenden länder
wir sind sogar weniger von gewalt
gedroht unser leben ist luxuriöser mit
einem knopfdruck können wir die
raumtemperatur kontrollieren
früher konnte man das nicht wir haben
also viele vorteile weil wir im
einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert leben aber
ja auch die ansprüche an uns sind
gestiegen
ich würde gerne eine welt sehen in dir
niemand in extremer armut lebt in der
die soziale sicherheit die wir in den
wohlhabenden ländern in west- und
zentraleuropa nordamerika oder
australien kennen dass diese sicherheit
weltweit verwirklicht ist dass jedermann
mindestens dieses elementare minimum hat
das wäre ein anfang
ich würde gerne eine welt sehen in der
wir tieren nicht enormes leiden zufügen
um sie zutiefst möglichen kosten in
dinge zu verwandeln die wir konsumieren
ich würde gerne sehen dass das aufhört
ich würde gerne eine welt sehen in die
wir nicht das klima schädigen für
künftige generationen
und natürlich würde ich idealerweise
gerne eine friedliche welt sehen in der
wir nicht mitkriegen beschäftigte und
oder milliarden von dollars für rüstung
ausgeben
dies zu erreichen wird sogar noch
schwieriger sein die dinge erreicht
haben dann sind sie in ihrer position
mit ihrer position stückweit arbeitslos
eigentlich habe ich glaube nicht dass
ich das erleben werde
das wäre fantastisch
ich hätte kein problem damit wenn es zu
diesen dingen nichts mehr zu sagen gäbe
da wäre noch das surfen oder bergsteigen
machen vielleicht gingen surfen wenn
sich das alles verwirklicht so lange ich
noch fit bin
oder wie sie sagen bergsteigen irgend so
etwas ich hätte immer noch gewisse
intellektuelle interessen sicher mehr
philosophie gibt es in einer woche
mein kollege juri steiner spricht mit
dem philosophen dominik keller und den
islamwissenschaftler uhr
rudolf über islamische philosophie und
über die frage wieviel orient heute noch
im okzident steckt für heute wünsche ich
ihnen jetzt erst mal einen schönen
sonntag
[Musik]